- On this episode we talk about pampering,
ad blocking, and politicians.
And feeling groovy.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] You ask questions!
And I will answer them!
This is the #AskGaryVee Show!
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 148
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Yesterday DRock stumbled hard
and created and awkward
show so that was fun.
Today we have a packed house with us
including a new Gary
Team member, Brittany.
Say hello.
- Hey Vayner Nation!
- Brittany comes from the LA office.
This is her first day on the team.
Going to work closely with Andy.
Excited.
- I'm pumped.
(laughter)
- And that's what's
going on at Vayner today.
Nice day, I'm headed to London.
Oh, I have to do my official
Jets prediction today.
Though there could be an episode
tomorrow where I do it there.
But we're not completely firm yet
that we're going to do an episode.
What do you think?
Safe way to go with the official
prediction in this episode.
Otherwise then we'd have a blank spot.
Okay, official prediction
at the end of the show.
India.
Let's get into
the show.
(playful arguing)
No, that's not going to work.
You can't fake me up.
Take that.
- Now you don't have questions here.
- Right.
So let's just do statements.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Susie says
"I get tons of emails
"from politicians begging for money.
"How would you do better
if you ran for president?"
Hashtag ready for Gary.
- Yeah, I mean look guys.
We've addressed this multiple times.
If you're new to this show I
will never run for president
because I wasn't born in this country
and if I can't have the top gig
I'm not playing the game.
How would I do it better?
Easy, it's the whole thesis
of all 148 episodes of this show.
It's all about depth, not width.
Like, nobody's winning the random
I'm going to blast you with email
give me 20 bucks game buy my stuff game.
The blanketing and
hoping and praying versus
the depth is the complete
misunderstanding of how to sell.
I think oftentimes it makes sense to me
that politicians are bad at this
because most of my politician friends
are terrible business
people and salespeople
so it makes sense and usually
you know, it's really, it's actually
stunning what kind of level of disrespect
I have for most politicians' salesmanship.
They can sell themselves,
but not other products
and I think that that at some level
is an intriguing aspect and
fine line in this whole thing
and so email marketing
is no different than,
you know, the direct
mail that they used to do
to try to get dollars
and so, I don't know,
I mean there's so many
ways to do it better.
I mean look.
I think one of the best
things a politician can do
is literally sit in the room,
sit on our God damn ass,
and for 15 hours, take a phone,
take a phone, and literally do,
and literally do, you know,
Twitter reply videos.
Literally search your name,
because everyone's talking,
and they either love you or they hate you,
because if you're neutral
you're in deep crap,
and just reply to them and say
"No Rick, that is not my policy."
or "Thanks Susie for the support."
It's the depth over the width game.
So the same stuff that
works in selling stuff,
selling anything, works in this scenario,
and so I think Twitter replies
I think would be
disproportionately powerful.
I think Facebook is the most important
platform for a politician due to the fact
that older people tend to vote
and that I think that
Facebook is the holy grail
of 45 to 70 year old reach right now.
Even better than television.
So I would put a lot of
content in that world
and talk more about my
policies and my thoughts
and more importantly show
the human side of me.
I don't know if people
have been paying attention
but I believe the last four
to five presidential elections
have been completely predicated
on a popularity contest
and we're in the
entertainment of politics era.
Not to get political, but if
you just look at all of them.
I mean like, whether you
hate Obama or you hate Bush,
these are likable people to those sectors.
In comparison we're in like complete
and what's going on now.
We are in entertainment mode.
And so I would be entertaining
if I had that opportunity
because that's what would work
and so that's what I would do.
I mean cold emailing is
doing absolutely nothing.
It feels completely cold.
It, you know, won't do it.
- [Voiceover] Ian asks,
"Gary, what's your opinion
"on incorporating curse words into
"your actual brand and
not just the content?"
- Yeah, I think that,
Look, I think that if you're
going to go down a path
where you're going to be doing something
that you consciously
know that a lot of people
aren't going to like
whether that is cursing,
whether that is before
mentioned politics, religion,
gender issues, you know, race.
There are pillars in our
society that evoke emotion
and have lines in the sand.
Cursing is one of them.
A lighter version than some of
the other things I mentioned,
but you have to weigh the
pros and the cons of it.
You will turn off a stunning
percentage of people by over-cursing.
And there will be a smaller sector
that is super motivated by it.
For me, it's just very simple.
Cursing for me is very simple.
It's just what happens when
I have the camera on me.
Like the more people that look at me,
it's what I do.
It's very, and so it's
just entrenched in me.
And so I believe that I
have to always at all costs
be me because that's my biggest upside.
If you're forcing the curse word
because you're targeting
16 to 22 year olds,
and you think they're
going to think it's cool
and it doesn't come from your soul,
you're going to lose.
But if your cursing comes from your soul.
If you are like, if you are like
this is peanut mother (censored) butter,
like this is it!
Like if that's where you
going with it, then like cool.
Like if I truly believe that people
have a stunning positive reaction
to disproportional authenticity.
I am an absolute biproduct of it.
I've watched as my maturity
and comfort zone with it has grown.
What's it meant to me.
It allows people to,
it's just a nice thing.
And so if you're
authentically there, cool.
But like coming from your soul.
Coming from your heart.
Not forcing it is the key regardless
of cursing, not cursing.
You know many people do the other side?
We don't talk about the other side.
You know, I always get talked about
being rogue or aggressive
or things of that nature.
What about the people that
are forcing the kindness?
Or the bullshit?
Like that's going on way more.
There's way more people, way more people
forcing the acceptance and approval
and following the path than are people,
that's why the people that
are going the other way
have disproportional anomaly results.
So how about that question?
How about any of the people
that don't curse when they feel it.
- I mean, I think that you should just
do what feels good, you know?
Do what feels right.
- Yeah.
Do what feels good.
And right.
Let's go, keep going.
You inspired a nation.
It's going to be a huge meme.
- [Voiceover] Mini says "Hustle is good,
"but often wears us down.
"Do you ever pamper yourself
"like maybe go in for a
pedicure or manicure?"
- Minnie Mouse?
No, Mini.
I was hoping.
Mini, do I ever pamper myself?
Not in the cliche like
I bite all my nails.
My nails are a disaster.
Now that I've been
working out for 15 months
Mike makes me do massages
because I need them at times
and I like it, it's nice.
It's a good thing.
No, I'm not really into,
not the cliche things.
I pamper myself by doing
whatever I want at all times always.
So I would call that
the ultimate pampering.
So that feels good.
That to me I think is,
by the way, that, you know what,
that might have been a
very interesting moment.
If you want to talk about
what the best outcome
of being a successful
entrepreneur, it's that.
The money is really fine.
The admiration is fine.
There's nothing close than knowing
that I could just get up right and just,
like, you know, like you noticed before,
like I slammed India's laptop
and she's like "great
you have no questions."
And I'm like "Great.
Great. What?
"What are you going to do about it India?"
So you know, like, I like that.
I like being able to do what I want.
I don't know what that just was.
If I want to get up for a second
I'm going to get up for a second.
I think the way I pamper
myself is if I do want to,
if I want to turn my
40th upcoming birthday
into a family celebration,
I can afford to do that.
That feels incredible.
And so I pamper myself by the experiences.
Going to London in a couple
of hours to watch a Jets game.
That's my pampering.
Doing the things that make me happy.
But, you know, I don't get excitement
out of a two hour pedicure
where I unwind and read gossip.
But many people do.
I walk around New York City
and watch it happen 74,000 times a day.
So, cool, awesome, do your thing.
So, you know, I don't, you know.
I'm trying to make my
life a pampering moment.
- [India] That's good.
- It's good stuff right?
Feeling like you should just
like always do what feels right.
(laughter)
- That's just not something I usually say.
It just came out.
- I get it.
It felt good at the moment.
- [India] It does, yeah.
Okay, from Brandon.
- It's going to be like free the people.
From Brandon.
- [India] Go into my hippie roots in SF.
- In SF?
You're doing just fine in New York too.
(laughter)
No?
- [India] I said hippie!
I don't know, I'm confused.
What's the question?
- Nothing, I just feel like you're
doing good hippie stuff here too.
- [India] Oh, yeah, I am.
- Yeah, yeah.
You said my hippie roots in SF.
I mean you brought it here too.
Oh, Andy, what did you say?
- [India] I brought it with me.
- Brought it with you, okay good.
I was just like say
that you said something.
All right, let's go.
It was.
I wanted to hear what it was.
Andy, I like Andy's game.
Andy has got the game of like,
he doesn't talk all the time
but when he says
something it's meaningful.
I actually, that was a genuine reaction
of like what did you say.
Because I actually value
the things Andy says
because he doesn't say them as often.
He's not quiet, he's not a mute.
But he talks when he, he talks
when there's stuff to be talked about.
I respect that, I really respect that.
I don't have that skill.
I don't.
India.
- You can counteract it with listening.
- Well I'm a tremendous listener.
This is the big, this is
the big unknown about me.
Steve, it's true.
- [Steve] I never said it wasn't.
- Yeah. India.
This is really starting to become like
the Z100 Morning Zoo
like just full of characters everywhere.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Brandon asks
"You don't talk much about ad-blocking.
"With more people doing
it, how will small and medium
"publishers and blogs survive?"
- They'll survive by adjusting
to the reality of the marketplace.
There used to not be ads and they would
make native content and soap operas
integrated their products into the shows.
The Ed Sullivan Show put a big fat car,
a Lincoln town car that paid
for that entire show in it.
And Alpo, or whatever that,
that's Alpo's dog food, right?
Alpo used to bring out it's, right?
Used to bring out the
dog on the Today Show
and eat the God damn Alpo
right in front of America.
And so ads my friends are
just one way to monetize.
I didn't run ads on Wine Library TV
all those years when everybody told me.
I decided to get paid millions
of dollars to write a book,
and to speak, and to
actually build an audience
and monetize them differently
instead of making nickels
and dimes on them.
Nickels and dimes are cool.
But you know what's way better?
Hundred dollars bills.
I feel like that's from the movie, right?
I mean that's what it is though.
And so I'm laughing at everybody's panic
because I think lowest common denominator,
average players are going to
get forced into being better.
I actually think this is
going to motivate people
to step up their game
and not just mail it in.
And so I'm excited to just
watch smaller and large.
You know, it's way more, you know,
it's a funny question and I'm sure
it's coming from an entrepreneurial place.
Big companies have a lot
more to lose than you.
Like ad-blocking, listen.
It's all relative right?
Like your 400 bucks,
their 40 million, fine.
But like everybody's equal in this.
Everybody's going to be disrupted.
Not just small businesses
and small publishers.
Big publishers that make
all their God damn money
on banner ads and things of that nature
have a real issue at hand and
I think it's God damn great.
Because what I think is actually happening
is that it's better for the end consumer.
I mean it is not fun for me.
Especially now that we're
on full, I need it back.
Sorry periscope.
How are you guys doing.
I'm just showing you DRock.
Actually I'll show you myself
because you don't want to look at DRock.
Well they'd rather look at me.
It's the #AskGaryVee show DRock.
You know, I forgot my thought
because I got mad at DRock.
You know, because, got it.
Because I don't want to go to like
ESPN.com and check a score
and a big fat banner ad pops up
and I got to X it and then I miss it
and then I'm going to
something I don't want
and that costs me six seconds
and time is the asset.
And so I really really think it's great.
I'm not talking about it because I've been
talking about intrusive
advertising my whole life.
This is just a continuation.
It will get, Tivo, ad-blocking,
whatever comes next.
Feedblocker.
Like whatever it is,
it's all going to happen.
It's all happening India.
- It's all happening, feel good?
- [Gary] What else?
- [Voiceover] Rachel asks
"How does the engagement on YouTube
"compare to other social platforms?
"Is the reward worth the effort?"
- Absolutely. YouTube is like literally
one of the great platforms of the world
in the engagement's very high,
there's tons of, matter of fact,
I put on my phone, I
won't take it this time,
I just put YouTube finally
at the front of my phone
because I'm engaging more in the comments
because there's so much going on there.
And thank you so much for everybody
who's watching the show on YouTube.
The engagement's super
worked, I won't even,
who said this?
- [India] Rachel.
- Rachel!
- [India] I'm sorry Rachel.
- Don't be sorry India.
Rachel, come on!
What do you mean the engagement?
Have you not seen a video on YouTube?
Even shit videos have like
three people saying "You suck!"
I mean they don't even waste
their time to do that on Twitter.
The engagement's incredible on YouTube.
The commenting is bonkers.
Videos that do well get tens of thousands
of people saying things.
Maybe YouTube's the best
engagement platform on the internet.
I mean, Rachel.
Sorry Rach.
Statement of the day.
Would love some comments,
Be interesting.
I feel like this really did
take the most radio-like vibe.
Curious to see what
people think about that.
Glad this show went
back to its normal self.
And that's it.
Oh, official prediction.
Official Jets prediction.
I've been very hot.
I mean I had probably like
40 to 60 emails this week
of like getting excited
for my official prediction
because are now going to
bet heavily against it.
So please want to first make note
that this is not official endorsement
or any legal ramifications of you
following this advice is on your head.
I don't know what.
(laughter)
Official prediction.
I believe that the New York
Jets will win this weekend.
I think that the Dolphins are
broken from the head coach down.
And I feel like the Jets will win.
I feel like Ivory will play this weekend.
I'm still pretty worried about Decker
and think he will not play.
My gut tells me.
Or if he does, it's going to
be very cautious, limited.
But we'll see.
He might play.
They do have a bye
week off of this,
so I think a lot of guys are going to go.
And I think they match up well.
I like that it's a neutral place.
I think London's an international town.
Let's call it what it is.
New York is a better brand than Miami.
And I think they'll be a
little bit of love for that.
And so I think that the
Jets go into Wembley
where I will be, super excited.
And pull this game out 19-14.
I think it's going to be tight.
I don't think there's going
to be a lot of scoring.
Unless there's turnovers.
The way my prediction gets off
is too many turnovers and
scoring which could happen
though Tannehill like, there were
a lot of interceptions last week,
Not usual for him.
19-14 New York Jets.
You keep asking quesitons.
I'll keep answering them.
When it feels good.